une semaine après le dramatique accident
qui a coûté la vie au petit homme deux
ans et demi les parents de l'enfant ont
décidé de se constituer partie civile
auprès du juge d'instruction pour
comprendre ce qui s'est vraiment passé
sur ce passage piéton ce sont des gens
qui sont particulièrement digne et qui
souhaitent avoir des explications
c'est quelque chose de difficile à vivre
pour des parents l'instruction est
relativement longue ils attendent de
savoir ce que va dire la justice est
d'essayer de de comprendre quelque chose
qui est pour eux incompréhensible les
premiers éléments de la reconstitution
qui s'est déroulé la semaine dernière
évoquait un homme fragilisé souffrant de
surdité une question reste donc en
suspens le conducteur âgé de 81 ans est
il encore apte à conduire notre système
judiciaire est fait de telle sorte qu'on
ne peut pas empêcher quelqu'un de
conduire tant qu'il n'a pas causé un
accident mais il y a une responsabilité
morale je pense que chaque conducteur
doit apprécier s'il est capable
physiquement ou psychologiquement de
conduire et il ne doit pas attendre
d'avoir un accident pour s'arrêter de
conduire et je pense que ces gens qui ne
sont plus capables de conduire et qui
continue néanmoins conduire sont des
criminels en puissance il y ajoute ben
ça vide juridique
notre gouvernement est très prompte à
réformer en matière de sécurité routière
très étrangement en ce qui concerne la
conduite des personnes âgées aucun texte
n'est passé alors j'ai peut être un
début d'explication ça tient peut être
content du fait de l'âge de nos
parlementaires qui ne souhaite pas
légiférer dans un domaine où ils seront
peut-être bientôt concernés
l'automobiliste a été mise en examen
pour homicide involontaire et délit de
fuite et placé sous contrôle judiciaire
avec interdiction de conduire et de
repasser son permis il encourt sept ans
de prison et une amende de 100 mille
euros